Bonjour et bienvenue sur My4Cents.
Alors, l'intuition ? C'est quelque chose
dont on a beaucoup parlé dans les dernières vidéos
et je ne vous ai jamais vraiment donné
de définition, même assez peu rigoureuse
et pour cause,
j'ai bien peur qu'on a tous des définitions assez différentes de l'intuition
si je vous donne une définition,
il y aurait une grosse partie d'entre vous
qui ne seraient pas d'accord.
On a tous à peu près une petite vision de ce qu'est l'intuition
mais on n'est pas tous d'accord sur les détails
et pour aujourd'hui, ce dont j'aimerais vous parler,
c'est de la manière dont les mathématiciens
parlent souvent de l'intuition
qui est, je pense, un petit peu différente
de la manière dont la plupart des gens parlent d'intuitions
notamment on va faire sous l'angle un peu de la psychologie expérimentale
et les travaux de Daniel Kahneman et Amos Tversky.
Sinon, pour ceux qui se demandent,
je suis au Maroc et je vous présente le Mont Toubkal là haut
j'ai du mal avec le selfie
L'idée de Daniel Kahneman et Amos Tversky,
c'est qu'on a en fait deux modes de pensée :
le système rapide et le système lent
qu'on appelle aussi système 1 et système 2.
Et qui, grosso modo, correspondent à l'intuition et la raison
en gros, notre mode par défaut, c'est plus l'intuition,
le système 1 qui est très rapide, très réactif
ce n'est que lorsqu'on s'investit vraiment dans un effort intellectuel
que l'on passe en système 2 avec la raison
et qu'on commence à avoir des raisonnements un petit peu raisonnés
alors, on pourrait croire que du coup,
tout ce qui est intuition est mauvais
mais ce n'est pas du tout en fait
le point du propos sur l'intuition.
Ce n'est pas que l'intuition, c'est mauvais
l'intuition en général, c'est très très très bien
c'est ce qui permet d'avoir des réponses rapidement des questions difficiles
et c'est pour ça qu'on l'utilise beaucoup dans la vie de tous les jours
et qu'il faut l'utiliser
On peut pas prendre le temps de la réflexion sur n'importe quoi
Par exemple, si on est en train de marcher en montagne
Il faut pas se demander à chaque pas où est-ce qu'on met le pied
il faut faire ça de façon un peu mécanique pour que
notre système 2 puisse penser à autre chose
ou tout simplement pour que ça ne soit pas trop fatigant de de réfléchir
donc l'intuition, c'est souvent très bien.
Et c'est souvent très bien aussi en mathématiques
parce que souvent, ça permet de court-circuiter certains raisonnements
en disant, bah ça, ça va pas marcher donc je tente pas,
ou intuitivement, ça a l'air intéressant
du coup, on va pouvoir s'intéresser davantage à ça
donc l'intuition permet de nous guider de prime abord
même si l'intuition se trompe plus souvent que la raison
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas l'écouter.
L'avantage de l'intuition, encore une fois,
c'est qu'elle fournit des réponses rapidement.
donc il faut utiliser l'intuition, mais souvent le problème
dans la manière dont beaucoup utilisent l'intuition,
c'est que malheureusement
on ne fait pas attention à à quel point on doit faire confiance
ou on peut faire confiance à l'intuition.
et je dirais que ce qui manque beaucoup en général, c'est cette prudence
vis-à-vis de l'intuition.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut douter de toutes nos intuitions.
il y a des intuitions en lesquelles on peut avoir vraiment confiance.
Bien souvent, quand on fait de la recherche en mathématiques,
il y a des choses qu'on n'a pas démontré
on ne peut pas être sûr, et qui sont uniquement intuitifs,
mais on est quasiment sûr
on n'a pas vraiment besoin de le démontrer tout de suite
et souvent on va pouvoir se concentrer sur une autre difficulté, plutôt que résoudre cette difficulté technique
dont on est quasi-sûr que c'est juste une difficulté technique
du coup l'intuition permet de sauter des étapes de réflexion
sur lesquels on pourra revenir plus tard
si vraiment c'était une piste pertinente
à l'inverse, il y a des intuitions en lesquelles
on peut dire : tiens, ça a l'air d'être vrai,
mais on n'est pas sûr et c'est quelque chose d'important
c'est à ce moment là qu'on va sortir l'artillerie lourde
mettre l'intuition de côté
et essayer de justifier plus rigoureusement notre croyance en l'intuition initiale
Bref. Ce qu'il faut retenir, c'est que toutes vos intuitions ne se valent pas.
Certaines de vos intuitions sont beaucoup plus fiables que d'autres
qui sont sans doute vraiment remettre en cause
ou en tout cas, en lesquelles vous ne devriez pas avoir un degré de confiance très important
donc il faut faire super gaffe à la confiance
que l'on attribue à nos différentes intuitions
il y a certaines intuitions en lesquelles c'est tout à fait sensé d'accorder une grande confiance à ces intuitions
il y a d'autres intuitions qui sont plus discutables
et sentir
quel est le niveau de confiance à attribuer aux différentes intuitions
je dirais que c'est un quelque chose de
très très très très important
et ça m'amène à un autre point qui est le fait que les intuitions évoluent
les intuitions se corrigent, s'améliorent si possible
se dégradent parfois
l'intuition que vous aviez il y a 10 ans ne sont pas les mêmes
que celles que vous avez maintenant
et je dirais même que le gros du
travail du mathématicien
le plus intéressant dans toutes les
mathématiques en tout cas à mon sens
c'est surtout
bien travailler nos intuitions.
Bien améliorer autant que possible nos intuitions
c'est pour ça qu'on adore les trucs contre-intuitifs en maths
parce que ça permet de nous remettre en cause
souvent ça va être un exemple lui qui
va être intéressant à méditer
derrière cet exemple, on va pouvoir repenser différemment certains objets
que l'on pensait toujours être d'une
certaine manière. Et à ce moment-là,
ça peut ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives,
et surtout, ça peut corriger l'intuition que l'on avait
au fait, là, je suis arrivé au refuge de Toubkal
qui est alors à 3200 mètres.
Il reste encore
900 mètres, 1000 mètres de dénivelé
avant d'arriver au sommet du Mont Toubkal
4h30. Il est temps d'y aller
on me voit pas du tout !
Il y a un joli lever de soleil
le truc important à retenir,
c'est que les intuitions évoluent
il faut être absolument être conscient de l'évolution de nos intuitions
et pour cela
il faut absolument être conscients de
l'origine de l'intuition
on peut absolument mesurer
le degré de confiance que l'on doit
attribuer une condensation
il faut essayer d'en déterminer
l'origine
ou alors
il faut vraiment avoir travaillé
ou avoir réfléchi longtemps sur
le degré de confiance qu'il
faut attribuer à nos intuitions
c'est vraiment la clé
bientôt arrivé !
le sommet est juste là-haut
et voilà les amis, je suis en train d'atteindre le sommet du Maroc
c'est juste là-bas
ça me permet aussi de vous parler de Terence Tao
Terence Tao est celui que beaucoup considèrent être le plus grand mathématicien de notre temps
ce que Terence Tao appelle lest 3 phases
de l'apprentissage mathématique,
et qui correspond aussi
aux trois phases
du bon travail et de la bonne compréhension de nos intuitions
et de la bonne utilisation surtout de nos intuitions
la 1ère phase, c'est la phase pré-rigoureuse
c'est ce qu'on fait à l'école maternelle
on joue avec des numéros,
on joue avec des figures géométriques
y a des trucs qui marchent, des trucs qui marchent pas.
On ne sait pas trop pourquoi
mais c'est les maths que l'on fait
et pendant, très très longtemps, y compris au lycée
le très très très gros des maths, c'est juste des maths pré-rigoureuses
c'est-à-dire sans rigueur
et pour moi ça a changé notamment au lycée
avec la démonstration par récurrence qui a été un peu une révélation
notamment appliquée aux sommes téléscopiques
pour moi les sommes téléscopiques
souvent le professeur disait que ça se téléscopait
et ça marchait
mais il n'y avait pas de preuves rigoureuses
et quand j'ai découvert la démonstration par récurrence
j'ai commencé à comprendre que toutes les mathématiques pouvaientt être rendues rigoureuses
Bien sûr
la phase très rigoureuse des mathématiques
c'est pas le lycée, c'est plus la prépa
ou les études supérieures en général
là on commence à apprendre des définitions formelles
on ne se permet plus de dire
"aussi grand que l'on veut" et des trucs comme ça qui veulent rien dire en fait
et à ce moment-là, on rentre dans la phase rigoureuse
on essaie de tout tout tout justifier
cependant pour Terence Tao
cette phase rigoureuse est indispensable à l'apprentissage
mais, cette phase rigoureuse est aussi inadapté
à une vraie compréhension des mathématiques, et en particulier
à la recherche en mathématiques
et du coup, il faut passer à une phase post-rigoureuse
où on commence là à vraiment jouer avec notre intuition mathématique
en parallèle avec la rigueur mathématique
mais en particulier à ce moment-là ya
beaucoup de résultats en mathématiques
que l'on va intuiter
que l'on va croire
bien avant de se mettre à vraiment les prouver mathématiquement
donc là j'y suis !
le sommet du Maroc
Mont Toubkal
Quelle altitude ici ?
4167 mètres
la phase post-rigoureuse dont Terence Tao, concrètement c'est quoi ?
concrètement ça veut dire que la plupart des raisonnements se font de manière intuitive
et c'est comme ça que se passe la recherche
si vous voulez prouver quelque chose qui va  faire trois pages de preuve
vous pouvez pas être précis dès le début
vous devez d'abord travailler avec les intuitions
et ce n'est qu'une fois que les intuitions sont claires
et que vous avez une idée précise
de là où on s'en va
en particulièrement quand vous avez une intuition quasiment aussi sûre que possible
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on va se mettre
à déployer tout l'arsenal
de la preuve mathématique rigoureuse
mais d'une certaine manière, la preuve rigoureuse mathématique n'a pour but
non pas de prouver ou de certifier que les choses sont vraies
mais c'est plus un sanity check
c'est plus pour vérifier qu'on ne raconte pas des conneries
Comme le disait Grothendieck
alors je ne me souviens pas de la citation exacte de Grothendieck
mais en gros, ce que disait Grothendieck, c'est quelque chose comme
il faut d'abord être parfaitement convaincu, que les choses soient évidentes
avant de commencer à essayer de les prouver
en particulier, il ne faut jamais essayer de prouver quoi que ce soit qui n'a pas l'air encore évident
et du coup vous sentez bien là que tout le jeu des mathématiques au final
en tout cas si l'on suit les pas de Poincaré, Grothendieck et Terence Tao,
c'est surtout d'affiner l'intuition que l'on a des objets mathématiques
et de certifier tout cela, de mettre un tampon sur la validité de notre intuition
quand on sent
que c'est pas assez clair.
Et à ce moment-là, on écrit une preuve mathématique
mais même dans une preuve mathématique, il y a souvent plein de détails qui vont être sautés parce que sinon c'est trop long
c'est trop chiant à lire tout simplement
pour que les autres relisent.
Et à ce moment-là,
une preuve mathématique c'est avant tout une façon de convaincre les autres mathématiciens
et on les convainc en leur montrant que les intuitions derrière certains trucs sont suffisamment évidentes
pour que l'on puisse être capable d'en faire la preuve
s'il voulait vraiment tout revérifier.
Voilà, un petit 360 encore
et c'est pour ça qu'en séminaire de recherche, la 1ère question qui est posée, c'est jamais
est-ce que la preuve est juste ?
c'est toujours : quelle est l'intuition derrière ce résultat mathématique ?
parce que l'intuition est beaucoup plus importante.
Une fois qu'on arrive à raisonner avec la bonne intuition
on peut aller bien plus loin
en particulier, quelque chose à travailler, c'est l'intuition pour laquelle l'intuition est bonne
le fait qu'il existe des preuves mathématiques souvent
va corroborer une certaine forme d'intuition
même si en général, ça ne va pas prouver
exactement la bonne intuition
mais ça va juste la corroborer.
Et de la même manière, un outil très utile en mathématiques, c'est les exemples
comme le dirait David Hilbert
les mathématiques se résument souvent à trouver le bon exemple à la fois suffisamment simple
pour être compris, mais aussi suffisamment représentatif d'un phénomène plus général
et du coup, raisonner avec ce genre d'exemples
c'est typiquement quelque chose que notre intuition va pouvoir faire
très facilement très rapidement
pour pouvoir comprendre l'ensemble des objets qui ne sont pas exactement cet objet là
on descend maintenant le long d'un glacier
et donc, cette histoire de phase post-rigoureuse de la réflexion
malheureusement c'est un truc qui n'a
aucun sens pour ceux qui n'ont jamais connu la rigueur
malheureusement je crois
et malheureusement ça a très peu de sens pour ceux qui sont encore en phase rigoureuse
où ils cherchent à être tout rigoureux partout
et ils ne se rendent pas compte que pour aller très
loin dans la recherche mathématique
et donc en mathématiques en général
donc on peut pas passer trop de temps à
justifier les bases rigoureuses
et on est obligé de, un peu, admettre
des trucs qui sont clairement vérifiés par notre intuition
c'est pour ça que
à l'intérieur des articles de recherche parfois, y a des phrases comme
"il est clair que" ou "il est évident que"
c'est pour faire parler davantage l'intuition que la rigueur
et ça a l'avantage de raccourcir les preuves et surtout de donner une vue d'ensemble des preuves
parce que malheureusement trop souvent,
notamment au niveau prépa
on s'enferme dans la rigueur
on s'enferme dans toutes les étapes de calcul,
et on perd de vue
le Big Picture
qui est le plus intéressant en fait pour un mathématicien
à grande échelle
on pourrait croire que du coup on est revenus au point de départ
puisqu'avant on comptait sur l'intuition, et maintenant,
on compte encore sur l'intuition dans la phase post-rigoureuse
mais en fait on a beaucoup avancé
En particulier, la grosse différence
entre la phase pré-rigoureuse et la phase post-rigoureuse
c'est que, en phase post-rigoureuse,
normalement on sait pourquoi est-ce
qu'on pense ce qu'on pense
on comprend l'origine de nos intuitions
et par conséquent est capable de donner
un certain degré de fiabilité
à chacune des intuitions que l'on a
et c'est vraiment ça, je pense, la clé
pour pouvoir bien réfléchir, il faut avoir
des bonnes intuitions,
et pour avoir des bonnes intuitions
il faut être passé par une phase rigoureuse
où on cherchait vraiment à chaque fois à dire pourquoi est ce qu'on pense ce qu'on pense
malheureusement cette phase rigoureuse,  y a très très peu de gens l'ont vécu
sur des sujets plus touchy comme la politique
les gens sont jamais passés par cette phase
je vous invite à un peu récapituler tout ça parce que c'était pas très clair
une vidéo un petit peu improvisée
no, no, sorry (à un vendeur de tapis)
where are you from?
Vietnam
Ah Vietnam! Oooooh!
Classique...
Donc je vous invite à récapituler ce My4Cents
qui est un petit peu pas super bien préparé, je suis désolé
ce qu'il faut retenir de ce My4Cents, c'est surtout que les intuitions
c'est un atout pour réfléchir,
c'est même indispensable pour réfléchir
je ne sais pas comment on peut bien réfléchir sans intuition
malheureusement le problème, c'est que bien souvent, les intuitions que l'on a,
eh bien on sait même pas d'où elles viennent
en fait il y a même des origines génétiques
notamment des recherches
par Jonathan Haidt, par Steven Pinker
Et bien sûr, si on ne connaît pas l'origine de l'intuition, on est incapable de savoir si on peut leur faire confiance
donc un gros travail indispensable à faire sur les intuitions au préalable
c'est de savoir quel est le degré de confiance
que l'on doit attribuer aux différentes intuitions, et pour cela le mieux
c'est encore de savoir d'où est-ce qu'elles viennent,
de trouver l'origine des intuitions
et une fois qu'on connaît les origines des intuitions, on peut même
les améliorer les affiner, ou compléter les intuitions avec d'autres intuitions complémentaires
comme c'est souvent le cas en
mathématiques, on aime voir les objets
sous différents aspects, on aime avoir plus intuitions différentes
d'un même objet. Par exemple, un vecteur y a pas mal de façon de se le représenter intuitivement
si y a un truc à retenir de cette vidéo
c'est que les intuitions, c'est pas quelque chose de fatal et inflexible
les intuitions, c'est quelque chose qu'il faut nourrir, modifier
et mettre à jour au fur et à mesure
et pour ceux qui connaissent, bien sûr,
tout ce que je suis en train de vous raconter là, c'est ultra bayésien. Je suis bayésien.
donc c'est My4Cents,
ça vaut ce que ça vaut, et je vous invite à mettre vos avis dans les commentaires